[Music]
hello oh is this you oh yeah come on no
this is the different car did you order
a Drew bar Wow Come On In
wow Drew
you're so cute oh by the way you guys
this is Ronnie we have a fan in a car
together for many many years and we're
very close and we're mobile roomies
hello hi Ronnie pleased to meet you
thanks for picking us up yeah anytime by
the way guess what we're playing game
is there something that your parents
don't know about you yes my parents
don't know that I bought a car at 14
years old and used to drive to school I
had a license too
as soon as we sat down I was like
I took someone telling me that Sable
which is the sexiest name ever it is
genius Elvis backwards and then you know
Sable being this incredible beautiful
rich brown color yeah you know and we
thought oh wow wouldn't that be a great
name or skincare okay let's talk about
this campaign picture who was like we're
going shirtless you know we were like
yeah but the thing is Idris was like no
you know we should like it should be
serious instead of the second we got in
there he's like fine
also it's skin care so I actually like
that you're showing skin not only is it
sexy and beautiful and a great choice
but it matters and it tracks this is
another question I have you know people
are really bullish on don't go to bed
angry but sometimes some time can give
perspective we we do hate going to bed I
agree we try never to but the times that
we do in the morning we're so snuggly
and like I'm gonna go to bed angry guy
what's a red light it's a red light if
you ever fart under the covers and then
go like this
I do fart under the covers but I just
put it over a head and just hold it down
and she's like I would die
but this morning I woke up and she was
like wait I did I did not what and also
sleep Parts don't count by the way
that's the cutest part
you laughed okay purposely said nothing
I wanted to be how I was dying every
woman who wants to fart just like that
make the noise again
that's what we want it's that's better
than that
I'm doing it for the TV but it was more
like this yeah
a little bit
literally dream of working with their
partner what's the hardest part of it
the hardest part is that we are both
opinionated we have actually quite
different approaches to some things well
I think for me the most difficult part
is coming home and there's like a
thousand things that we need to talk
about but I don't want to compromise
home time because I want those hours
where we have like dinner and it's us
and we can talk about anything but work
why are you not driving now because I
wanted to talk to you and concentrate
but Ronnie is the best driver in the
world and Ronnie also tried your skin
care and it's time for Ronnie's review
yes please give it to us straight no pun
yeah well the toner I loved it didn't
seem to strip everything away from the
face the moisturizer was awesome wasn't
too strong in the scent which is perfect
for me it overall wonderful wow and yet
the packaging that's what caught the eye
running thank you for giving us that
review because you know men do not talk
about skin care and the routines and the
things that work for them and Sarah I
really appreciate it Ronnie is this a
red light red light okay no
um stop sign but we asked you a question
who's one actor that you would love to
work with that you haven't worked with
yet
Jim
Carrey oh Jim Carrey God now I think
I've messed up everything you can do it
take two Drew if you had one actor that
you want to do your next film with who
would it be
[Music]
Jim Carrey
[Laughter]
we are here at your destination
thank you so much don't forget to leave
me a review
well I'm so excited they gave me a good
rating phew okay well I would drive
around with them anytime oh and you can
get Sable Labs products now at
sablelabs.com and listen to Idris and
Sabrina's audible podcast coupledom
anytime
[Music]